of creepy oh man hi hi everyone right oh
that's my bug zapper I'm gonna turn that
off for this video that feels like that
shouldn't be on for this okay hi hi
friends hi friends hi friends hi friends
hi friends
hi friends hi friends um okay bear with
me as I get settled into this because if
you guys know me you know every single
time I do this I don't know what I am
doing but we're still that doesn't mean
I shouldn't try right let that be a
lesson for you
already so many lessons uh we have a
just so you guys know I don't even see
where oh there she is there she is
we have a spectator in the house right
now she's upset because I'm paying more
attention to you guys than to her like
mother like her daughter okay I'm going
to announce what I'm doing via social
media and which I am I'm just trying to
I'm tweeting this out you guys okay
sorry sorry I'd be so all over the place
but you're gonna watch me do so for me
to do right now ready
hi I'm live on my channel
come hang out or don't it's your life
Jovie won't be there
okay you're witnessing a really good
tweet
this is where i spell-checked bon jovi
because i don't want to be an idiot bon
jovi phonetically spelled exactly as it
sounds okay okay okay okay
hi guys hi um thank you for joining me
on this livestream um a well firstly
what's happening in the world I just I
should have checked that first to make
sure oh my god it's a first look at Lady
Gaga's Joanne world tour oh my god also
there's this photo of what where I go to
check news if I feel kind of behind I go
to Twitter moments and I just saw one
the main one right now is the first look
at Lady Gaga's Joanne world tour and -
there's one that says brie Larson opens
up about getting Captain Marvel right
and she's is like going like this with a
hat and she looks exactly like mamrie
guys go to your Twitter moments right
now and look at that photo and tell me
that that doesn't look exactly like
mamrie Hart that's bonkers I'm just
going to check on everything that's
happening really quickly to make sure
that nothing is like actually like so so
awful that we should all pause this
moment doesn't seem like anything's I
mean everything's always everything
anyway great sentence Helbig hi guys
nice to see you here thank you for being
here ok I'm gonna go open this on my
thing so I can see comments coming in
and actually be able to respond to stuff
ok sweet yeah hey just setting this up
was already exhausting enough I feel
like I have adrenaline dump and we're
like 4 minutes into this hi everyone
my name is Grace albick if you did not
know now you know your life is different
now I did not make a video yesterday so
I wanted to do a livestream today as
compensation for that probably not
adequate compensation but it's something
I got back from Montreal last night late
last night
maimry hart and i were up there
performing in a Comedy Festival called
Just for Laughs Lilly Singh superwoman
she hosted this Comedy Gala gala and
there was a bunch of comedians
performing in it and main brain I got to
perform in it it was super fun pun
intended I guess and for some weird
reason the only food that I ate like the
whole time I was there for every meal
was nachos so Canada you guys love
nachos is that a thing because every
menu that I saw had some version of
nachos on it maybe it's just a Montreal
thing but I I went to town it was
awesome and I loved every second of it I
don't need to change it just threw me
for a second
glad to hear that you guys like not just
very cool very cool uh so I think you
like every live scene there's no real
plan for this it's just sort of talking
with you while my fur daughter Oh
protects the castle you guys see this
thing alert an attentive and protecting
the castle I think she's very not on
edge but just like more into her duty of
protecting the castle because a raccoon
got into our yard like last week and it
really freaked her out and I
to get it out via screaming and spraying
things at it it was a time you guys
it was the time and then I was awake for
the rest night by myself tasers and bear
spray on Amazon so make sure that you're
fully protected in every aspect of life
I think that's a great lesson Wow
there's already been a lot of lessons Oh
some just ass isn't my dryer in the
background yes that is my dryer I am
doing laundry right now because I just
like to one screw up the audio on a live
stream and to subtly let you know that
I'm like really responsible so there's
that uh are you excited for VidCon
Australia
I am excited for VidCon Australia anyone
out there watching in Australia right
now what time is it in Australia it's
totally 2018 I don't know how time zones
work but I will be at VidCon Australia
and soon if not already you'll be able
to know everything that I'm doing
they're doing a bunch of fun panels and
Meetup and some cool stuff and I've I'm
just excited the only other time that I
had been to Australia was two years ago
two years ago with Hannah and memory we
did a nofilter show tour through
Brisbane and Perth and Adelaide and
Sydney and Melbourne Melbourne Melbourne
and so I'm really excited to go back and
do VidCon in knellman it's how you
supposed to say it apparently and I feel
like a dick thing at Melbourne for
Melbourne anyway how are you guys this
fine Tuesday afternoon I honestly I
always panic before I do live streams
because I'm like would I have to get
everything ready and I have nothing
prepared and it's live and I can't edit
it
I always end up putting on deodorant
before I do live streams so you guys
should feel very privileged that even
though you can't smell me I'm trying
really hard to be okay for you come back
to Minnesota whoa
I mean I like Minnesota the Mall of
America is extra yeah I mean that might
be the definition of extra I'm an idiot
and I try so hard to seem young and hip
and cool and that mall is being very
extra anyway I think these types of
things because there's no plan our best
structured if you guys have any
questions let me know and I will try to
answer them as quickly as I can read
what is happening on the screen so if
you have any questions feel free to ask
away oh my god already I can't breathe
where did you get your shirt of this
shirt is adidas but I'm not sponsored I
just like it breathes mesh it's got tiny
holes everywhere so tiny little wind
gusts get into all your skins did my
tampon just fell out I hope it didn't
but you know that seems like a personal
issue do you know that we almost got hit
by an asteroid last week I did not know
that but that's another fun thing to put
on the inbox of anxiety issues to
address at some point thank you for that
how was goose she'sa oh my god can i
zoom it oh I can't
I literally just tried to zoom in look
at this thing she's pretty good
I think she's doing pretty
Oh
where did I get that Flemming go ahead
this woman go ahead this from the target
children's section because I I've a
child uh what were like Keaney next I
don't know I should get more will like
Keaney episodes in before the end of
summer I assume so send me a comment on
the last will at Keaney video different
fabrics or elements or things that you
think I should kini cuz that's where I
look for the ideas for it what I should
Kimmy how am i doing emotionally fine
good even sometimes and then bad
sometimes it's a you know it's like a
metronome right that's not what the book
is there gonna be another no filters
short show tour in Nebraska know where
we want to work out tour things we are
talking about tour things and a
multitude of different varieties of
tours that could possibly happen so
hopefully we figure something out soon
um
it's always painted into our social
media that sounds so dumb anyway did you
figure out your hair no I don't know
what's happening with it it's uh this is
this thing all the things it's it's this
now this is what it is now yeah that's
what it is now it's fine I washed it
this morning so life's looking pretty
cool what's that clicking noise in the
background that's my dryer cuz I wash my
clothes because I know how to be an
adult fave wine all this brand called
all ALL means all the wines
it's pretty pretty good where are you
traveling to next where am i traveling
to next mm where am i traveling to next
I think Australia might be the next
place that I'm going to there's a chance
I might be going up to San Francisco
next weekend but I don't know for sure
but Australia that is the most concrete
travel for VidCon Australia if any of
you are going please let me know I'm so
excited
uh oh man I am not good at reading
quickly can you call mamrie I can I
won't but I can cuz I think I have
mamrie on Twitter alerts when she tweets
out and I'm pretty sure she tweeted out
that she's going to a dance class so
that doesn't seem correct and also
mamrie and I only call each other when
there's like a major issue here's a
funny story
so at Montreal Just for Laughs maybe and
I did the show and then we came back to
our hotel we went to the bar and we're
having a drink with her college roommate
which is so crazy or college roomie just
happened to be in Montreal at the same
time that we're doing her show and we
had a couple drinks with her and then
they were gonna go out and I went back
up to bed and when I got to my room I
get a FaceTime from mamrie and I
immediately turn it off because we don't
FaceTime each other we don't call each
other we text normally and if we may
MERS very very notorious for butt
dialing myself and Hannah a lot I texted
her I said you accidentally FaceTime me
and she was Rebecca it's on purpose
and the night fixed I figured she was
kind of another thing to tell me about
her friend from college anyway that
story was better in my head than it was
out loud hey do you ever miss New York
City um yeah I do there are these brief
windows in the spring and in the fall
when New York City is the best but the
weather is beautiful and everything
seems pretty and asked for
a tional and it feels like you it's a
concrete jungle where dreams are made
but then you quickly remember that like
there are so many layers of your and on
atop the concrete jungle
and that's who's just did an impression
of what New York sounds like all the
time that's what New York sounds like
all the time it's just constant noise so
the point that like I have to go to
sleep with a fan on or music on or a TV
on because I'm so accustomed to just
hearing noise when I fall asleep that if
it's too quiet
I don't like it do you like Harry Potter
what oh my Harry Potter house is
Hufflepuff just for all of you that want
to know I think it's pretty accurate so
I'm pretty excited about it
upcoming podcasts yes oh and a lot of
upcoming podcast guests um if you guys
for those of you that don't know I hope
you know I do a podcast called not too
deep you can listen to it on soundcloud
in itunes and we've had so many amazing
guests this week but we also do we shoot
full episodes that go up on the full
screen app and then they go up on
Soundcloud night UN's a week later so if
you have full screen you can watch the
full episodes or SoundCloud and iTunes
you can listen to them and we've had so
many cool guests on this season that
it's bonkers to me we I think code eCos
episode you can listen to on soundcloud
night UN's right now for free let me
double check that because that was so
fun I think Cody Koh is one of like the
yeah
Kota ko is the most reason listened to
you for free on soundcloud iTunes and he
to me is one of
the funniest people on YouTube coming up
in this like new generation of YouTube
right now and it makes me really excited
and just talking to most like you have a
good head on your shoulders
ah this is such a relief that there is
hope out there for the future of YouTube
and we have Nathan Zed on an episode
that will be coming up soon and he is in
that same boat of people that I'm like
you weren't good and you just you please
do good which makes me happy so get
ready for that you guys uh what is going
on wait where did mmm God guys reading
come to Columbia maybe perhaps I don't
know Never Say Never
Murch oh yeah
there's some interesting merch in the
works right now interesting meeting like
merch I've never done before that I'm
really excited about that goose had a
part in that I think you guys are really
gonna love and it will be announced in a
few I don't know weeks I don't know I
don't know but it's really cool it's
something I've ever done or made before
and it's taken a really really long time
but the final outcome is so hilarious to
me and like I said goose has a heavy paw
in it and it's gonna be fun anyway
have Alaska from RuPaul's Drag Race on
oh I would love that favorite popcorn
flavor
i weirdly like smart pop or skinny pops
like salt pepper flavor so there's that
there goes a billion subscribers Game of
Thrones do you guys watch Game of
Thrones what you think I don't watch it
oh you can tell me anything but I want
to watch it this you I've watched on and
off I know to some degree what's
happening at certain moments but I don't
know all of it
so I have to start watching I heard that
there was a I see on Twitter moments the
headlines about things from Game of
Thrones so I can be a context clues
understand what's happening but I don't
know it's someone said it's lame what oh
wow that's an opinion I have never heard
about that show so cool
favorite show question mark I am an
idiot cuz I like Bravo reality
television i watch all Real Housewives
of everything and it is uh it's really
fun it's really dumb and it's hard to
like promote it but it's just nice get
your brain out of your brain sometimes a
favorite band what's my favorite band
probably hmm probably Hanson
because I look like every single member
of them right now
bachelor in paradise I is it available I
haven't watched it yet is it up and
running I know that like bad [ __ ] went
down with it and they stopped filming I
am more of a fan huge fan of unreal have
you guys watched unreal
it's on the Lifetime network hold on I
gotta actually see when oh my gosh when
is unreal season 3 did it happen already
what unreal season 3 delayed until 2018
wha
ye ah it's fine okay
I love unreal on lifetime it is the
scripted overdramatized sort of version
of the bachelor or bachelorette and it's
so good it's like a soap opera meets
like the OC meets the actual
Bachelorette meets like I don't I love
it it's so good and all the actors and
actresses are so good on it and I watch
season 1 and season 2 which i think is
probably on lifetime not sponsored at
all I just genuinely liked it so so
deeply you can probably watch it on
lifetime calm and season 3 as I've just
learned has been delayed until 2018 uh
unreal unfair sorry I just got possessed
by me my heart for a moment anyway wha
any upcoming movies working on some
stuff I mean I don't have anything to
like say specifically right now but
there's a lot of fun projects like in
the works but you never know what's
gonna actually happen which is why you
don't say anything about it because
there's always a chance that something
doesn't happen even though it seems like
all signs point to go so I can't say
anything because I don't want to
disappoint you if it doesn't happen but
there's a lot of fun potential things
that could happen and I'm with you that
I want to know what they're happening so
I could tell you that's that happening
what should I name my puppy oh I don't
want that responsibility at all but I
think maybe you guys should give some
suggestions on a good dog name and maybe
that person can um figure out what they
like from their waffles or pancakes
pancakes because pancakes are just cakes
it's just cake it's just cake in the
morning it's just cake in the morning
and most days that's all I want
uh well well well when I come teach a
class at the Pitt the people's Improv
Theater we should do improv I I don't
think I would teach of class because
I've been out of improv for like five
years now and so it scares me
I've like done all the training perform
to perform a form and then like dropped
off so now I feel like I'm back at the
beginning now and I need to take classes
again which maybe I will
who knows pickles or sauerkraut pickles
pickles over most things how the [ __ ] do
you even read these and barely look my
eyeballs are at an all-time stress level
what what react to kpop oh maybe I
should what are oh oh okay I'm clocking
out in my brain as an idea for the
future should I dye my hair red yes what
color is it now
but I think yes pizza or pasta I think
pasta because Pizza is always cheese
which in theory is grapes in digestion
is bad I'm regretful and awful
were you a Nickelodeon kid yeah yeah I
was i watched uh growing up I watched
the Amanda Bynes Show or The Amanda Show
I watched Rocko's Modern Life I watched
Rugrats I watched a Arnold I watched
there on I watched all that I watched my
brother Tim tonight we're talking about
stick Stickley the other day do you guys
remember that literally the host of
Nickelodeon was a popsicle stick with
googly eyes on it how did they get away
I mean that cost them $10 Cindy stick
stick me was an icon and for years he
was like the Carson Daly of Nickelodeon
and Nickelodeon figured it out they're
like ok TRL MTV you guys have a VJ that
you're gonna pay lots of money to we're
gonna go around all that saver money
we're gonna use a popsicle stick and
we're gonna have the same effect oh I
missed that um oh my gosh here we go
uh-huh Oh secret life without Mack yes I
used to watch that too where she turned
into the puddle of ooze and then when I
don't I can't remember even what was the
premise of that show just more beanies
and like layered outfits a lot and then
turned into a puddle and like slipped
under doors which is probably like an
invasion of privacy in hindsight but um
I remember being like she's cool and
also an outsider
that makes me like her more
senior year of college advice have fun
this is your last year of like this
safety net that you have but do well set
yourself up for success going forward
into real adult life but enjoy yourself
don't don't think too much about it
being your last year easier said than
done just be in the moment of things
also easier said than done and uh keep
asking people other people for better
advice what do you advise for freshmen
freshmen going into college ok if you're
going into college um it's going to
imeem I'm giving this advice my
perspective is based on the fact that it
would feel very very tiny school I call
it fake college sometimes because it was
like all of my friends went to like real
like massive colleges my college was
very small so my experience was very
different than them but I will say go in
with an open mind find people that you
have similar interests in and take the
time to find good people it takes time
sometimes um don't settle for a friend
group and think that that's it shop
around a little bit I get involved in
different like activities or things or
clubs or whatever it might be
um and enjoy yourself figure out like
know that you're gonna be a crazy person
you're gonna be a whirling dervish and a
maniac for the first like a couple years
and that's the safe place to do it you
don't want to necessarily do that in the
real world colleges like this you know
like trampolines have those netting
things around it so you don't fall off
the trampoline real life is like a
trampoline without that netting around
it so College is like the trampoline
with the netting around it so do all the
flips that you want get caught in the
netting let it bounce you back keep
going and then when you get to the
trampoline without the netting hopefully
you're a little bit
did I just make the most amazing analogy
of our lifetime perhaps anyway and if
you can't do flips just play that game
popcorn everyone loves that okay
would I ever come to Trinidad and Tobago
yeah I wouldn't say no to it have you
been to Ohio Oh have I been to Ohio
maybe I used to watch Drew Carey
Cleveland rocks all the time I'm aging
myself so I feel like I've been up oh hi
oh and I'm good friends with Mitchell
Davis who is like the president of Ohio
so um I feel like I've been there but
probably not thoughts on tattoos sure
it's not my body uh where did you get
your plant this plant here I don't know
for sure that plant looks awesome but
the ends of each of these leaves are
straight up needles like actual like
needles like it will hurt you so um I'll
leave that plant there and I let it do
its own thing I don't really like hang
out with it or get near it I tried to
vacuum around it earlier and it hurt me
and then I realized it's like an emo
teenager it just needs to be left alone
and then it'll go out on emo night and
like feel fulfilled so have you been to
Utah I've driven through Utah there's
that come to Puerto Rico I've never been
my younger brother's been he loved it so
much I would love to go there feelings
on tacos yes all the time please
Lollapalooza question mark question mark
question mark exclamation point
exclamation point exclamation point
where's goose Oh
so I love you can see it but there's the
tiny cow laying with her head under the
couch right now it is likely that she
found either a toy from weeks and weeks
pass that is under the couch or she sees
the shadow of just a dust ball and she
thinks it's a tennis ball and she's just
gonna leave her head under the couch
passively aggressively waiting for me to
come and um help her because she doesn't
have arms fav drag queen oh I don't know
that one's so hard
uh I oh man I don't have a favorite I
appreciate every drag queen because
they're doing stuff that one I it's just
so impressive everything they do is so
insanely impressive on so many levels
just like artistry ability to create
things and and and comedy comedic timing
and just like oh it's so impressive to
me I it makes me feel inspired and
insecure in it goose just say um
thoughts on palm trees they look like
they're gonna fall over any moment gonna
read me a lot of myself they just like
stick up there without like trying too
hard just like awkwardly there but
you're always a worried that they're
gonna fall down
so a little bit like myself uh
Playstation or Xbox or Nintendo I don't
want to Paulo as an audience so all of
the above
grace here it's already Wednesday happy
Wednesday you've made it through half of
your week already congratz
what everyone's obsessed with this
flamingo thing if you guys never seen
this in my house I guess I feel my
kitchen is that way so I guess I only
filmed this way this flamingo thing is
like it's from the target kids section
I'm not proud of it but there you go
how was just for laughs
it was so fun soo so fun and there are
so many hilarious people that perform
there that make me feel like what am i
doing I gotta get better at comedy
they're very very very very very very
good um so it was fun do you like black
mirror yes I do like black mirror it is
intense and unpredictable and that's
what I like about it that every episode
is completely its own like short film so
you don't know what to expect and you
can't follow like a full narrative and I
like it very much
when's the new season where did I get
this shirt this is a guys I don't I'm
not sponsored um do I like sense8 I've
never watched since 8:00 is it is it
good is it worth it I mean I'm I need
new shows so give me new shows to watch
did you see Tyler's five call thing yes
I did
I'm trust me I'm trying to film I got
tagged in Tyler uh plays five calls
thing and if you haven't checked your
house go over to Tyler Oakley's channel
and check it out so I have to do that
it's on my list of things to do trust me
trust me trust me I'm gonna try and do
it do I miss attack of the show yeah I
do miss attack of the show it was such a
cool thing
for you guys that don't know attack of
the show is the show on a network called
g4 it was one of my first like acting
gig things that I got hired to do and it
was hosted by Kevin Pereira and
originally a little Olivia Munn
that's where I met Chris Hardwick he was
a correspondent on the show and it was
so so so much fun it was just a show
where people were really excited about
what they were doing and talked about
all things like tech and pop culture and
nerd and all of it it was great and I am
so thankful that that had that
experience to be part of it I learned a
lot about like how TV shows are made and
I learned a lot about how to be a great
host because every host on that show was
excellent um Oh have you guys anyone
paying attention to Star Trek
the new series that's coming up with the
female captain I just saw a magazine
cover earlier and it made me so excited
I'm not a Trekkie but I want to be
anyone out there because it makes me
stupid excited and I think I saw from
comic-con there's like the first openly
gay character and the captain is a
female uh how do I get caught up could
you guys actually I mean like I want to
know it get into this and then I had the
super into Star Trek and I've never like
really felt I've known of it but I've
never really followed it is there what's
the easiest way to get caught up on
episodes tweet me or leave this in the
comments below and I'll go through so I
can check it out because I'm really
really excited about it and also I just
want a new series to pay attention to
because Real Housewives can only sustain
me for so long I think I need something
with a little bit more substance no
offense Ramona
oh honey oh honey I got you I got you oh
yay thank you I'm very excited
have you ever seen the Sandlot yes I
have seen that but I haven't seen it
since I was younger so I don't fully
remember what I mean I know kind of the
premise and I know that goose reminds me
of the big slobbering dog that was in
the field next door and sometimes people
referred to her as that so we all get
like celebrity comparisons who's the dog
from Sandlot Korean barbecue or Tex Mex
oh I gotta go Tex Mex oh god it's so
good um where did you get your table
this table this is West Elm this table
um I've seen a couple people with it
it's pretty cool I like it doesn't do
bad things but I won't I was gonna talk
about like the wood grains getting like
salt and pepper stuck in it but that's
not that's not a conversation for now
yes I also don't follow Doctor Who and I
know someone just said that the new
doctor in Doctor Who is a female which
makes me also very excited so if you
guys have I where's the best way to
catch up on Doctor Who I mean all of
this is so much content to catch up on
but I'm very I want stuff I have some
free time ish right now and so I feel
like I should just be ingesting content
well I have the time and and those seem
like really fun things to catch up on
thoughts on PewDiePie at the moment I
love cutie-pie I'm a big fan I haven't
watched has he done anything bonkers
bonkers I haven't watched it a little
bit but his review of the Jake Paul uh
yeah Jake Paul's everyday bro music
video oh it was so good it was
so so so so good made me smile but I
haven't been catching up on what's
happening now upcoming not too deep
guests we have Nathan said it's coming
up we have oh man I forget about
everyone immediately after we shoot and
it makes me so bonkers oh wait huh no
we've Nathan said we have oh my gosh
my brain is a graveyard because that's
where thoughts go to die I'm going to be
shooting soon okay this weekend
with Thomas Sanders is coming on and
Aaron and Carly who are in that whole
like Liza Koshi david dobrik Scottie
toddy grew up and so I'm so excited
they're coming on this weekend and I
can't wait because they're all people
that I think are really good and fun and
are just like doing great interesting
fun stuff on YouTube and just in general
on the Internet
so I have anything I'm just selfishly
bringing them onto the podcast so that
they inspire me to get back into the
game do i watch American Horror Story I
do not but I wish it it um that's
another one that I've heard is nothing
but awesome what camera do I use a great
question I use a 70 D or 60d camera it's
somewhere around in my house hopefully
goose literally is like a cat now she is
up on the corner of the couch like she
cannot pick a spot
and I love her for it she doesn't settle
she goes wherever she wants
where are you reporting from my house um
what what what can we have more vlog
miss I was thinking of wanting to
possibly maybe and this is so vague and
wishy-washy do some sort of vlog every
day scenario for a bit maybe just test
it with like a two-week period or
something just to I want to start doing
some new stuff on my channel and maybe
and I have some ideas for like new stuff
on the channel just to break it up
because I've been doing all this for
like you know going on ten years now and
so feels like it's time to start
experimenting with some new things and
not feel burden to the restrictions that
are currently in place so I might try
and do some more vlogging if I almost
think it through a little bit I don't
commit to it without being able to do it
so I'm gonna think it through but if you
guys want me to do it let me know I I
just want to start just doing new stuff
and not feel like I have to keep doing
the same stuff over and over cuz that
makes me sad because then I feel like
I'm not doing as good as I could because
I'm it seems a little old or tired or
reused to me anyway la la la la la la la
thank you for being tiny not tiny but
like a thank you for a tiny therapy
session very quickly um
mace or heart big oh god I will never
answer that that's like yeah I'll hit
myself over the head with the rock
before I answer that question that's
polarizing and they a lot of people have
asked about writing a book I'm it's not
official
and I'm trying to figure out what I want
to write a third book I haven't started
yet I I want to figure out what is
something that makes me excited the same
way with the videos I want to figure out
like new stuff to do that I've just get
re ignited in my excitement for I want
to figure out a different type of book
to write that makes me excited X I've
done Grace's guiding grace and style and
there are options for other like that
tone of book but maybe there's something
else I don't know a lot of just like mmm
brain thoughts haze of ideas happening
which for someone that's very indecisive
it's not necessarily the best headspace
to be in but it's figure it out
eventually anymore answer ants I hope so
that depends on our ants they are fickle
little ladies if they've had enough
rose' then probably but we'll see uh
write a joke poem book Oh trust me
that's one of the thoughts that's one of
the ideas that's rattling around in my
brain memories book thoughts get ready
that's all I can say uh favorite
Starbucks drink
I don't like Starbucks that much but
stay with me I don't drink any of the
milkshakes that they bring it doesn't
bring me to the yard they're milkshakes
but I I their coffee just tastes like it
was burning for a long time then they
just let it burn and then they put it in
a cup and it tastes burnt so I will
drink it if it's available and there's
the only thing available but I don't
particularly like it but that's what
coffee just serves the purpose to either
one mess with your digestive system or
to wake you up and get your brain going
for the day vlog dude okay I'll think
about it
thoughts on the emoji movie I haven't
seen it has anyone seen it is it out
already does anyone know what's going on
with it I read reviews that seemed very
aggressive and
negative way and I don't know what to
think about it so I kind of want to see
it because the immediate reviews were so
bad that it makes me curious and also
who knows you know it's mob mentality a
bunch of people ii think something it
affects the way you truly perceive
something but excuse me good ice that's
disgusting go on tour okay I will try
excited for season two a stranger thanks
yes
wait when is oh my god I haven't watched
the I haven't watched the trailer for
season two yet I saw that they dropped
it at Comic Con I haven't watched it
yeah I'm gonna do that after this
livestream I'm gonna do this live show
for like an hour so he's like 19 18
minutes left um and then I'm gonna go
and watch stranger things and shoot a
video for tomorrow when is stranger
things season 2 when does it come out
they announce the date that it comes out
should I watch it right now do you guys
want me to watch stranger things right
now should we watch it all together oh
my god okay wait I'm gonna wait wait
wait okay everyone pull up the trailer
of stranger things and then I'm gonna go
get a drink real quick because I'm now
too excited about this okay so everyone
get the the trailer ready cuz we're all
gonna click it at the same time oh my
god oh my god I'm gonna take a shot real
quick guys cuz I'm I'm too excited about
this oh my god okay
great job doing a great job okay okay
okay okay okay oh [ __ ] okay yes built
okay wait let me hold on wait let me
find I mean let me find it
oh my god I just told you guys how to do
this and I haven't even done it oh my
gosh we're so excited okay this isn't
you trailer okay wait wait wait
which one is it
wait which one is the official trailer
is it the one that's three minutes in
four seconds on the Netflix yeah that
one's got eight million views I'm going
with that one but okay what I'm pausing
it wait cheers guys okay okay ready guys
three two fun play
I want their wardrobe I wish I owned all
the clothes that all the boys on No
[Applause]
why he's been through so much already
[Applause]
that looked like a varicose vein you
guys I'm getting hives right now
[Music]
[Applause]
the pump dealing of the pumpkin stand up
I know
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
understand that makes the happiness of
the beginning of brother
[Applause]
[Applause]
now
[Applause]
[Laughter]
wait and we wait October 27th oh my god
who said to leave the room where it was
I'm sugars
I can't I can't was Bart where's barb
and i miss barb
was she in there she wasn't I
oh my like actually have hives all over
my body right now that was too exciting
holy [ __ ] uh Wow
I love stranger things i when I first
started watching the first season I like
just binge it until it was done I'm
gonna check on honey I got your own
goose I gotta make sure there's no
raccoons in the yard again hold on I
know your show I know it's a lot and all
these kids are way too young to do it
like the PTSD that they're gonna get
from whatever is happening to them oh my
god
it is oh okay
should we do I mean wait so that it's
it's dropping all the episodes at once
again are they I just got really anxious
asking that question like a maniac
person
all episodes October 27th what do we do
to celebrate that let's the right thing
we have time we have time to plan party
plans this but we should probably do
something to celebrate all of this maybe
the following week we'd do like a recap
livestream of it because I'm gonna have
to watch them all right away huh
those kids are great actors the whole
series is fantastic
I'm obsessed with it they're all so good
they're all so nice they're also like oh
uh wait oh my gosh what's this oh my
gosh oh my gosh oh my gosh oh my gosh
okay oh my gosh oh my gosh I don't need
to repeat things I just okay the do you
guys know olan Rogers at all he's a
youtuber and if any of you watch how USA
with mamrie night he was in the
Indianapolis episode with us he went to
the baseball game with us and now he has
none he's amazing he's so cool he's like
one of the first like wave of youtubers
with like Mitchell Davis and all of them
and he came down and did hey WA say with
us because we were near him and he he
has a new show this is so crazy
yeah wait what is this on and make sure
he's got this this animated show on TBS
called final space that one of the boys
some stranger things is voicing a voice
in and so it's crazy to me it's so
awesome but like not only that he's dead
like this entire insane a list celebrity
cast but I saw the other day because I
follow all the kids from stranger things
on Instagram and it makes you feel weird
but I do it and I'm and I saw that the
kid from stranger things posted that
he's in this thing that I need like
thanked : for allowing him to be in this
like cast of people and I was like
worlds are colliding in a weird way I
mean the upside down is right-side up
for a moment
um yeah like Fred Armisen is in this
show Conan O'Brien David Tennant like
it's insane uh
bonkers bonkers bonkers but so that's a
that's a side thing that's a that's
sorry a tangent if you will
oh my gosh so we we should do something
for stranger things let's start figuring
this out oh gosh oh gosh oh gosh I'm
I feel like I I have all the emotions of
going bungee jumping or skydiving
without doing that physical activity so
I am on edge in a very positive way to
say the least
wow wow wow wow oh man okay
we only have like eight minutes left of
this livestream so um I don't know what
the best scenario is maybe if you guys
have any questions feel free to let me
know I'll just be breathing kind of
heavily to catch up on my heart beat
have I met any of the cast of stranger
things no I have not met any of the cast
of stranger things but they all seem
like great human beings and I do look up
them on Instagram probably more than I
should as a human adult woman thoughts
on Hanna's show yeah Hannah Hart has a
Food Network show that's coming up and
we're gonna be doing like a viewing
party on the 14th when it airs on Food
Network LLC here yeah Monday the 14th
Hannah's new show I heart food har T
premieres on the Food Network and we're
all gonna hang out and drink and watch
the show and potentially live tweet and
all that fun stuff so get ready someone
else am i sad that mid night is ending i
am sad that at midnight is anything but
i'm actually tomorrow going to film the
final episode of @midnight I don't know
if I'm loved I think I'm allowed to say
that
pretty sure I'm allowed to say that um
there's the bringing back as many
contestants as they can to film the
final episode and then they're throwing
a goodbye party so that's gonna be
tomorrow get ready for the social media
coverage of that
event have I seen master of none no I
just finished on the flight back to Los
Angeles yesterday Atlanta and it is so
good it is so good that it makes me like
uncomfortable because it's so good I'm
like oh man yes yes yes yes yes yes so
but I haven't watched master of none I
should watch that grace I'm glad you're
alive I read otherwise oh here I am I'm
alive and so it's that thing just she
likes to sit in every suitable place in
the living room as much as possible she
doesn't want to participate in the live
stream she says beforehand and then she
just slowly makes herself closer and
closer to camera as we go on
how tall are your uh I'm 5 foot 9 inches
tall and that's my bodyguard
have you seen Grayson Frankie no it's
another serious that I haven't watched I
don't see I have a hard time sitting
down the reason I like Bravo TV is
because I feel like I can do other
things while I am watching those shows
and I don't need to be like fully
focused on that the same way
I'd rather text people then get on a
phone call with them because I feel like
getting on the phone um I have to be
super focused and then that I don't know
it's it's a selfish thing but I've heard
that that show is fantastic and I need
to watch that
[Applause]
how did I not get a notification I don't
know did I do it wrong I want to do more
live streams in the future as I've said
every single time I do a live stream I'm
like I want to do more live streams so I
should probably figure out all of the
like buttons to push and write things to
do preemptively before I start doing a
live stream and also figure out how to
like have just like things around me -
if I end up watching a trailer for a
show I like too much that might calm me
down because it was now prepared not
prepared who riverdale everyone keeps
asking upriver day oh I haven't seen it
another one I should watch should I add
to the list
everyone loves Riverdale where what is
Riverdale on MTV
Netflix River drill is not 13 reasons
why right there are two separate things
Riverdale sucks
someone said okay it sucks okay
well it's an interesting I mean they the
best shows that the ones that polarize
people that get them talking either too
good or too bad right I don't know how
does art work what is goose holding you
hostage no no no no no if anything she's
protecting from people that might hold
me hostage don't watch Riverdale Wow
okay
are you watching the Eclipse
wait there's a solar eclipse are you
that must be wet wait I Oh I'm live
sharing on my phone otherwise I have a
moon app on my phone let's see yeah
Oh filled in
yep
what solar eclipse is coming in August
here's what what what what what what
what is it where is the solar eclipse
whose what are you barking no okay this
is a lot of reading I don't want to read
on camera um if someone holding you
hostage in a very tiny room no that's it
this is my living room my kitchens over
here um KaBlam that's the kitchen so
that's I'm like this looks the angle my
iPhone right now looks like it doesn't
look like I'll figure this out
eventually a better angle to do this all
that I just threw this up for now but no
no one is holding me hostage but if they
did I'd be like this kidnapper Shops at
Target a lot good for that Walking Dead
Season eight I am I've been after like
season three maybe four I stopped
watching Walking Dead and then it got
too much to try and catch up with so I
should but I haven't but I should uh
haters back off season - yes Coleen yes
Brooklyn nine-nine I should watch that
yes same same same house torque I mean
didn't hear some of it
should may should maybe call it soon
oh don't hey I'm calling I'm at 58
minutes and 53 seconds I'm gonna make it
to an hour you guys we're gonna do it
Rick and Morty another one that I should
watch everyone loves that low-set loves
it loves that damn I'm late to the party
yeah you are how dare you
Bachelorette I I watched the first
couple episodes and then I fell off and
then I saw that the Mantella was last
night and I kind of just want to start
with the men tell all because that's
fascinating I heard there was actually a
really great conversation that happened
on it so we'll see um but I'm gonna
widen this down you guys this was really
really fun thank you for tuning in and
and watching the game of Game of Thrones
oh god guys my brain is scrambled on
great programming watching the stranger
thing season 2 trailer with me that I
haven't even fully processed as at the
moment I might go watch it again as soon
as this is done but let's talk more
about what we can do to celebrate the
game of oh my god wires are crossed
thing synapses are firing incorrectly
right now so that means I definitely
have to go
I am shook a--the in the all the ways so
figure is for watching this live stream
I want to do more as always I will let
you know follow me on all social media
at grace Helbig that's the easiest way
to find out when I'm doing live streams
cuz they are not announced very well
beforehand and sneaky when they're
happen I hope you guys have a great
night happy Tuesday to all of you and
I'll see you next time how big is that
good night
you